tom brady 43 years old meeting with the
media for the first time
since his introductory video conference
when he signed with the buccaneers in
the offseason
shireen uh look
i i i think tom brady's greatest
quarterback of all time
but and we just we we just played part
of what he had to say
you know he was specifically asked about
his concerns as it relates to covet 19
and this is a guy who defied the nfl
pa's
recommendation oh it was just a
recommendation well yeah i mean
recommend
so just because they're not forcing you
to not do it doesn't make it something
that you should maybe consider
you know complying with but the nflpa
said
uh several weeks before camp no more of
these group workouts until we get to
training camp so we can have proper
safety protocols and
tom brady basically gave the nfl pa
middle finger he was asked yesterday
about
his concern as it relates to kobe 19 and
he
it was like two sentences of nothing and
then he pivoted into an extended
commercial for the entire tb-12 method
he
never really drilled down to whether and
to what extent he has concern
and here's the bottom line even if you
think you have honed your body to a
point where as gardner minshew
said earlier this week if the virus sees
you it's going to run the other way
the reality is if you test positive even
if it doesn't affect you you test
positive
you're shut down you test positive on a
saturday
you're not playing the next day so you
know
even if you never have a symptom
right this is just some arbitrary thing
that plucks a guy out of a locker room
puts him over on the side and says
you're not playing this week so
for that basic reason every player needs
to be concerned about covet 19
including tom brady
when tony romo was in the cowboys locker
room
i never thought he would be good at tv
after he was done
and the reason is because he talked a
lot
and said very little and i get that same
thing with tom brady
you know the the media never asked the
question that you just said as about
these offseason workouts he had
against going against the nfl pa mandate
not to do this and they never ask it and
i don't blame the media for that i know
those guys
most of those guys very well i covered
the tampa buccaneers
a long time ago but i i covered it with
many of those guys still on the beat
but the reason is he spent 11 minutes in
a press conference and answered six
questions and said
basically nothing in this entire press
conference and
you know as you said mike as you noted
eating well
sleeping well doing all the things you
need to do to be a good player on the
football field have
nothing to do with whether you get
covert or don't get
coveted frankly it's a lot like going to
las vegas it's it's
hit or miss it's it's luck of the draw
whether you're gonna get this thing or
not and
and so there's nothing you can really do
aside from staying away from people
wearing a mask
and taking the precautions and even then
there are no guarantees you're not going
to get covered we all know people who
have had covet and some of them have
been
worst case scenarios and that whole
team beat writer's press conference
dynamic it has so many different facets
and factors to it
you know and and let's be realistic
right if this is the team you
cover you don't want to piss off the
starting quarterback
in his first training camp press
conference by asking him a bunch of
hostile aggressive questions and trying
to
cross-examine him on why he defied the
nfl pa mandate
you become persona non-grata and all of
a sudden
you can't do your job anymore i mean
there is part of that reality and then
in a press conference there's always
that kind of like
well i'm not going to really be the one
to ask that really delicate difficult
question maybe he will or maybe she will
i just
and before you know it it's over when
you throw in the ever present
filibuster option where you can take six
minutes to answer one question be
completely non-responsive
and just run out the clock i mean you're
right that's what he did yesterday
it was an 11 minute clock he ran it out
by giving long answers and he never got
pressed not that he would have gotten
pressed
he never got pressed on some of the
choices he made and how he harmonizes
that now
with the idea that they're trying to
keep people safe and trying to keep them
from getting
coveted 19. so we got another tom brady
clip from yesterday let's see what he
had to say we'll react on the other side
i'm glad we're not playing a game you
know this sunday i'm glad we have time
to prepare
uh you know it's it's it's been a good
week
or so being in here and i think every
day i'm trying to take advantage of the
opportunity to
improve myself so that i can be the best
quarterback for this team that
that this team really deserves these
guys are working really hard and
and uh you know i want to come in here
and do a great job for them
easy to do a great job when you have
great players around you shireen that's
the one thing we can't lose sight of the
buccaneers and the saints get together
five weeks from
this sunday and when you look at the
talent around tom brady
guys that collectively collectively he's
never had a crew like this he's had
randy moss he's had wes welker he's had
flashes
but all of these guys that he has
available to him with mike
evans chris goblin rob gronkowski oj
howard cameron braid i wouldn't put
lesean mccoy on that graphic because i
have a feeling ain't gonna make the team
they have ronald jones to be their lead
running back i mean this
is talent this is ability this is
something that tom brady can really make
hay with
if he has enough time to throw but the
one thing we know about tom brady
he makes his decision pre-snap he knows
where the ball is going to go
and he gets rid of it even if the
protection falls apart but that's really
the lingering question
shireen in this offense how long will he
hold the ball
we know bruce arians likes to get it
down the field will brady hold it
and will will the offense work
if the offensive line isn't performing
at the highest possible level
well i think you also have the question
mike of how much does brady have left
you look back at last year he wasn't
very good
so was it tom brady or was it the fact
that
he didn't have any weapons to to throw
to he didn't have any weapons in the
backfield he doesn't have the weapons
like he has now in tampa and that's what
we're gonna find out he is 43 years old
and we saw it with peyton manning you
know the the career just kind of went
off the cliff there and he ended up
winning a super bowl but
they did it with defense i'm not
positive this buck's defense is quite as
good as that broncos defense
uh was when they won super bowl 50. but
i think that's what we're going to find
about
about tom brady is how much he has left
and and whether it was the weapons he
had in new england or whether it was
the fact that tom brady's on his last
legs or his last arm however you want to
put it
legs are the key not the arm i was told
several years ago by somebody who has
studied brady very carefully he'll be
able to throw like he does
into his 50s it's the legs it's the
ability to get
away from guys who now are
i mean i've been rounding up or rounding
down and saying you know he's
he's facing guys who are half his age
there are guys now
half his age who are chasing him around
and if he cannot get away from them and
we've seen him bail out multiple times
he throws
the and and i'm not questioning in any
way
his courage right it's smart
if frank clark is bearing down on you as
you're getting ready to throw the ball
on fourth and goal to julian edelman to
potentially force overtime against the
chiefs
and you choose to make a half-hearted
throw because you need to curl up in the
fetal position before frank clark sends
you into the front row
you do it when you're 42. uh but but
those business decisions those very
smart business decisions
that affects your performance and at
some point you're just not going to have
time to even make that business decision
at some point
the legs are going to go to the point
where he can't avoid getting hit
once he starts getting hit he's going to
get hurt and it's going to be like
peyton manning
in 2015 where it was just duct tape and
glue to try to hold him together for a
full season and eventually they had to
shut him down
and eventually they brought him back
with just enough
to to just limp over the finish line for
that super bowl championship and that
that's a real factor and it almost feels
sacrilegious to say that about tom brady
but hey if you're going to play into
your mid-40s this is part of what you're
going to have to deal with the question
of whether or not father time
isn't going to get you in the off season
father time may get you
during a game in october it may all
happen
that quickly and that's part of the
fascination of watching tom brady play
this late into his career shireen
oh i can't wait and i think we're
excited and we're excited by the bucks
for the first time in
forever uh since at least the early
2000s when they had that great defense
and you wanted to see what warren sapp
and derek brooks and all those guys were
going to do and i know the tampa fans
are as excited as they've been since
then and and we all want to watch them
and we all want to see what tom brady is
going to do and if he can lead this team
back to the promised land
where they've only been one time and
they've been bad in their history so he
gives them hope
right now and if he has something left i
think they're going to have a really
good time in
in tampa we saw with joe montana led the
chiefs to the playoffs when he went
there you know we saw it again with with
uh peyton manning when he went to denver
and he didn't exactly lead them to the
super bowl title but but they got there
and they won it and so we've seen a lot
of these quarterbacks go on to different
places
late in their careers and have success
and bucks fans sure hoping that tom
brady has a little something left
because if he does he has a ton of
weapons
he can get the ball to and they're going
to make big plays for him
and and in the limited defense of peyton
manning not that he needs me or anyone
else defending him
i firmly believe that the broncos would
have won super bowl 50 without him
but they wouldn't have gotten there they
wouldn't have gotten past the steelers
and maybe not past the patriots if brock
osweiler had been
playing in those games so payton gets
gets
partial credit for the domination of the
panthers that the defense
finally pulled off but uh yeah it's just
an amazing
story for him to walk off into the
sunset with the super bowl we'll see if
tom brady can do the same although if
they win the super bowl this year he'll
probably
he'll probably keep going until the
wheels really do come off all right
we're going to take a break
pft props coming up could we see the
single season sack record fall a former
teammate of tom brady
thinks he can take it down more pft live
coming
after this
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports